all right we had a request from the
viewer to do Fox Next
there's a boy Fox let's see what kind of
outfit we want to wear I think let's go
that one right there
so Samus down Pikachu down now we're
gonna attempt classic mode with fox
mccloud one of the most popular smash
melee characters for sure oh man we
gotta fight Samus right here start
yeah Fox was was one of those uh top
tier characters and smash melee for sure
see how much has changed with him this
is my first time playing him on smash
ultimate he's still super fast still has
the reflect okay and I'm getting owned
right now
oh my gosh go ahead shoot it shoot it
shoot it shoot shoot it
[Music]
I actually don't know what Fox's
ultimate is let's find out
well crap does they have to be lined up
that was weird like that little
crosshair popped up but it didn't maybe
I just didn't move it I don't feel like
it gave me any time to line line it up
at all yeah if I lose the first one I'm
just gonna restart no reason to no
reason to play it out from there he ways
to continue yeah you know you know
Falco's gonna be the or wolf i mean wolf
could be in there too so I hate these
stages dude alright third time's the
charm
didn't earn any rewards it's all good
all right here we go let's try this once
more fox mccloud classic mode starting
off with Samus maybe that's what's wrong
I just don't want to I just don't want
to hurt my main character I keep wanting
to do the overfeed attack but the Fox
that's the one that would just send me
off what is this oh that's that weapon
from one of the Zelda games the like bag
that blows the wind she's done Oh
it used the the lava actually worked in
her favor right there
do you his attacks are so like it's what
makes him a top characters you can just
really combo them into other attacks
still no slippy now not that I've seen
no slippy as a playable character
alright so it started off with Samus in
Samus was at the left of this like
tapestry I don't know if it's changed
every time I should have been paying
attention to that Oh
Rosalina and luma okay sticking with
like the space theme now I got it oh my
gosh what happened did I like grab the
luma I know you could do that maybe she
like attached him to me
yeah that attack right there is the one
I'm afraid to do at the edge
I just don't know Fox as well at all at
playing him know him well from fighting
him
[Music]
oh nice good timing on that
I kidding me I used it at the edge over
there visuals are amazing I know dude
it's like I guess the Wii U was
technically HD right that was probably
that I guess that was their first HD
console yeah this looks even better hey
I don't see Rosaline in the graphic at
all there it did drop me to drop me back
I think it dropped me back Meta Knight
these are all characters I don't have
unlocked I feel like just for beating
them you should just beat him in classic
they should be unlocked see if you can
just yeah you can still just hold down
hold down a to do that the fast punch
that kicked right there dude the upsmash
I guess tilt so powerful with box
what was this like I know it's the star
from Mario Galaxy yeah I do Oh give me
that give me that give me that
I'm not even try to pick up the bunny
the bunny hat with a box
and that the item worked in my favor
we'll take it 5.5 Dark Samus okay
wait what zero suits in here - there was
nothing about zero suit or she on my
team
oh yeah she's helping me
Oh Bullet Bill I don't remember bullet
bills being an item
you just roll off Wonder Dark Samus is a
he or she
I mean you think she right if it's just
a dark version of samus he's gonna take
a lot my wife keeps saying he she just
can't take a lot of hits being the big
version but zero suit samus is here to
help me out save the day
round four is clear and we proceed on
okay so that one gave me I think that
gave me more points six point two is
over up to now captain olimar Oh more
such a unique character like period but
especially in smash she's I could never
control him but there are some people
I've ran into online that just so good
at using Olimar he's one of those
characters where you really have to
think outside the box when happen when
you use him he's definitely not a
traditional traditional fighter I mean
he uses his Pikmin to do the fighting
essentially right plus 0.7 again up to
six point nine here there is wolf
alright that must mean you're right
Christian probably be faithful at the
end oh my gosh dude alright well show me
show me the moves that I'm supposed to
use some of the best moves for Fox
I just remember Fox in the air was so
deadly
so all these moves and that them trying
to hit in the air probably pretty
powerful attacks
[Music]
Christian remind me what was like the
main purpose of the of the side-b move
that little - right there is there a
certain like spot where if you time it
just right it hits for more oh no no no
no no no no
[Music]
no use it 143 damage come on dude
the the like side be move the move where
he does this like the - oh okay
maybe that's it maybe the point of if
you like timing it where it hits at the
end it's more powerful because I always
feel like it's kind of a wasted move
because it leaves you so open but maybe
it's a timing thing maybe if you time it
right there - very in like I just happen
to do there by pure luck maybe that's
what makes it really powerful
oh crap
no no no go up this way this time
No
oh man oh you got to get up there quick
and then - right through that have been
a great time for that - move actually
these right here I feel like you got to
get over here fast enough and then
backtrack a little bit to get over to
them I don't know that this is that's
better than break the targets though
break the targets was always cool
because it was different for every
character it's kind of strategic for
each each character you had to sort of
plan out how you were gonna do it based
on their moves
okay so Master Hand that's weird
like when I play it when I cleared this
with Pikachu it started off with mu 2
and then Master had joined the battle
box here master hands just gonna come
right out off the bat with Sam aside to
fight Master Hand and crazy hand
dude how do you get out of the way of
that I'm dodging every time maybe I'm
maybe have to do
[Music]
maybe you have to do like the dodge
instead of the just block like I'm doing
yes we want to continue I feel like the
old classic you you started out with a
stop as well in this one you don't start
out with any stock it's just zero and
then if you die you have to use your
continues there we go
all right let's see if there's anything
after master Han this time has it's been
different every time at the end
anything anything don't think so maybe
it's based on your score in terms of
what you see at the end got it up to 6.5
with that one nice work